months munch frozen too hello everyone
welcome to today's live broadcast
microfluidic single cell exomes seek an
RNA seek analysis of tumor composition I
am Brenda Kelly Kim of lab roots and
I'll be your moderator for today's event
today's webcast is presented by lab
routes comm the leading social media
site for science professionals for more
information please visit us at
wwwbootysha calm before we get started
there are a few instructions we want to
hear from you during this interactive
broadcast so please ask questions or
leave us a comment answers are always
welcome to you can do this by hitting
the green QA button at the lower left of
the presentation window and type in your
comments and questions into the box will
try to get to as many as we can and will
follow up if we don't have time today if
you want a better look you can enlarge
the slide window by clicking on the
screen icon in the lower right hand
corner of the slide window if you can't
hear or see this presentation properly
please let us know by clicking on the
support button on the top right or use
the Q&A button lower left we'll make
sure we try and resolve any issues now
let's get right to today's presenter we
are proud to welcome dr. yiannis reduces
he has head of genome sciences at the
mcgill university and genome quebec
innovation center an associate professor
in human genetics at the department of
bioengineering his also affiliated
professor at the biomedical sciences
research center a Fleming in Greece and
the King Abdulaziz University he has
developed expertise in all fields of
genomics and functional genomics his
main interest is in developing NGS based
approaches to disease gene
identification as well as functional
genomics approaches for the
identification of prognostic markers and
associated pathways in breast cancer he
is responsible for the genomic platform
development within
the month McGill University genome
Innovation Center and Canada's genomics
Enterprise funded by cfi he chairs the
International Management Committee of
the McGill University and genome
Innovation Center and oversees the
genomic platform operation and new
technology evaluation and integration
his lab works on technical developments
including the single-cell genomics lab
and the mutation detection technologies
with focus on the genomic and
transcriptomic analysis of single cells
supported by CF the lab includes a fluid
I'm biomark HD instruments and two fluid
I'm CI instruments as well as an Oxford
nanopore min I on device both
single-cell whole genome expression
profiling as well as whole exome
protocols are validated and available
for external users please join me in
welcoming dr. reduces for his
presentation
dr. burgesses hello hello everyone good
afternoon I'm going to talk about the
microfluidic single selection sequencing
and RNA sequencing analysis
concentrating in breast cancer tumors I
would like to thank you for the
introduction and I'll start straight
away by saying that the most of the data
are going to show a result of a
collaboration between my group at the
McGill University in some Quebec
Innovation Center and Morag parks group
with a director of the Goodman Cancer
Center at McGill University further
collaborators have been some dahna batts
and Keith Sewell bar at fluid I go now
if we look at what we know about tumors
today is that if we need to apply sort
of specific and targeted cancer
therapies we have to know what are the
different subpopulations which consist a
particular tumor and what has been shown
is that there is a lot of heterogeneity
in terms of how different at tumors in
different persons look like so different
types of tumors in different persons are
different from each other but if we just
go and see an individual tumor we will
see that there are different subclones
or subpopulations of each table and to
make things more complications ear and
to make things more complicated if we
zoom into any one of these particular so
what is seen as sub-population that
belongs to the particular clone we can
see that there is heterogeneity also
within these populations as can beezie
by the behavior of different markers
either d
nay or RNA markers therefore one got the
idea that we need to analyze these
tumors at the single-cell level and a
lot of this has been developed by navin
just a few years ago and the idea is
that by applying single-cell genomics we
can actually achieve the resolution that
is required now to analyze the
individual cells that make each of
subclones within that solid tumor here
as this example and all the cells within
the tumor the next thing that is
important to consider for single-cell
genomics is that we don't have only the
tumor but then we also have as the tumor
progresses circulating tumor cells that
can be analyzed not to see how and what
properties they have that allow a
metastasis later on and also
disseminating disseminated tumor cells
that can also give an indication about
what drives the further metastasis and
development of a cancer in being the
metastatic regions in general there are
two ways to analyze the cells so these
can be isolated as we said other from
the tumor all from a liquid biopsy know
to identify the tumor cells or from
through bone marrow aspiration for
example at least can be analyzed either
now in terms of the DNA you know do that
we need to apply methodologies like
whole genome amplification I'm going to
touch little bit on that all whole
transcriptome amplification in order to
profile now they add the genomic in
taxes clubs the genome and transcriptome
of the single cells and guide further
drug development or our better
understanding of tumor biology in
general
now in order to do that there are two
main approaches nowaday and one here in
the top row there are methods that will
allow us to isolate any any single cell
from a population and this can be done
either by micromanipulation or serial
dilution law sorting all micro fluidics
or laser capture microdissection now on
the other hand individual and
specifically rare subpopulation like
circulating tumor cells can be captured
through other types of technologies like
the DPR a for example here which applies
dielectrophoretic cages so there are low
voltage currents that are used to
manipulate the cells and drive them
around and isolate them in a
microfluidic device it is also the
magnetic mark sweeper whereby little
beads coated with antibodies against
particular markers cell surface markers
for example up come that are markers for
CTCs can be used to enrich for these
rare populations from a big mixture and
then analyzed obviously these systems in
neuro be a row B can actually be
combined with methodologies like in row
a the other thing that needed to be done
was a development of technology that
will allow us to analyze the
transcriptome and key here have been
technical developments pioneered by Eric
for example by ricca-san tax group by
tank group and as in Serani and many
others who developed highly sensitive
RNA sequencing methodologies that allow
us to actually
generated at a cdna that reflects the
transcriptome of single cells and the
what has been key in these technologies
was the idea that you know either if you
could be here you use basically a primer
that matches the poly-a tail of the mRNA
and that files up a transcription and
the tick they reverse transcription and
the trick here is to enriched to enrich
for these transcripts and be able to
isolate in sequence them later on a key
development in this has been the
application of the smarter method what
is this it has a quite peculiar
characteristic which is that we use
again a primer that will start a reverse
transcription from the poly a tail of an
mRNA molecule but by using an lv reverse
transcriptase that has eternal
transferase activity here what happens
is that once once the enzyme finishes
copying the RNA into the first round of
DNA it starts adding a particular base
of the five prime end and the art here
is to get an enzyme that will are the
same days like see in this case at the
five prime end so several seas are here
synthesized and the system allows
actually now to incorporate a primer
that ends in complementary G Moloch
gee-gees that will anneal with the
seaford have been generated through the
terminal transferase activity and
immediately the enzyme jumps over and
continues synthesis of the complementary
strand from the five prime end and
that's where the name comes from it's
basically
it means switching mechanism at the five
prime end of the RNA template now once
you have the cDNA you can now generate a
library amplified and forward from
sequencing these methods have and other
similar methods have been developed have
the following characteristics I'm trying
to use an old view from a review of
peter von low end theory vet here you
can see that there are several methods
developed that cover either the five
remain or the three prime end of the
transcript this can have some advantages
if one is all interested tags that will
identify a particular task for example
but smarter or in this case is a method
that allows us to sequence complete
transcripts and it's comparable to
another method PMA or SMA in these
methods use polymerase to amplify the
RNA or semi-random primer based
applications they all yield comparable
results
now the microfluidic instrument that I'm
going to deduce how the following
characteristic just to put it in the map
compared to other methods it uses
basically a system whereby you can
visualize the cells will see this in a
moment but it has the characteristic
that it just requires something between
200 and 1,000 cells this is sufficient
as an input in order to isolate up to 96
different cells in comparison to other
methods it allows you to actually
visually verify the cells and it's
possible to link it with downstream
automations but that's also possible
with many other systems now other
technologies have been developed include
drop sick published last year for
example whereby now the cells are mixed
with beads carrying primers with not a
bar-coded and this method here on the
top left has the advantage that one can
now generate cdna from a very high
number of cells so it should this method
is suitable to characterize thousands of
single cells and commercial applications
of this idea or similar applications
include a system that is available from
10x genomics for example and this is
using the same idea of generating
droplets that capture single cells and
beads and perform the cdna synthesis in
the droplets and that allows you again
too
nice very high number of individual
cells other alternatives I cannot cover
everything but are the mainstream
alternatives that are available
commercially for example include the
system from way virgin here whereby it's
the same idea but the cells spread on
top of the chip that has again primer
combinations that allow you to perform
locally cdna synthesis and subsequent
library preps and it's also suitable for
generating cdna from life from about a
thousand individual cells now we have
used these the fluid I'm see one system
that captures 96 or more recently up to
800 individual cells for several reasons
which I'm going to go into and try to
make this work as a facility at McGill
University the the good things about the
system are that one can use this to
actually capture between 96 and 800
single cells and from there on you can
perform either whole genome
amplification and study the DNA or cDNA
or RNA which I'm going to touch upon a
little bit and from there on you can
link this to either high-throughput pcr
instruments like the bio mark which
allows you to interrogate 90s examples
with 96 essays or you perform next
generation sequencing using the cdna or
genomic DNA generated from single cells
now the cells are captured within the
chip and what is the trick here the
trick is that the cells are captured in
a very small volume which is as you can
see here four point five nanometers
initially
then it's the cells alized as the next
step any reverse transcription performed
with this material in chambers that are
increasing volume starting from nine
microliters and ending up to in 27 an
elixir in nanometers ending up in 27
nano liters and then after the reversal
exception is complete we have a pre
amplification reaction in order to
amplify the cdma further and that
happens in also in progressively
increasing volumes but again everything
is kept in a nanometer range which
achieves that they there is a very good
combination between high efficiency of
the reaction a minimum contamination
from outside sources since everything is
happening within a chip and completely
enclosed recently this has been improved
by reducing the these volumes further to
just a total of 26 to 27 9 liters and
able to capture up to 800 cells in one
chip now after you generate the cdna in
the chip we have important advance in
order to generate efficiently material
for next-generation sequencing was the
library preparation and this library
preparation is based on NextEra which is
a transpose a is based method basically
the cdna is incubated with transposase
enzyme which fragments the DNA and
allows the immediate amplification of
these fragments and the beauty of the
system is that these these PCR products
can immediately go and be sequenced in
an alumina sequencer therefore this
allows
anybody to develop highly efficiently
enough efficient and automated methods
it's a simple workflow and indeed
degrades also the method integrates
indexes that allow you to multiplex high
numbers of samples and sequence them
efficiently in terms of cost now I will
given a work of some results from one
example that we have investigated in to
some depth and it shows here an approach
whereby we want the moral gloves marks
lab takes material from the tumor that
is treatment-resistant it's a breast
tumor then the tumor is propagated in a
mouse model as patient-derived xenograft
and then the cells from tekzilla graft
can be used as a culture as an excellent
culture or analyzed in more detail in
tissue sections for histo chemistry and
what has been shown before we went on to
analyze the tumor further was that if
you look at the primary tumor from which
the sample has been arrived and the
xenograft and the histology is the same
and the characteristic of this
particular tumor was that was here
negative PR negative n had some hair to
positivity
so the system that was set up as a model
system was to actually investigate the
tumor and single cells di from the
patient dr8 derived xenograft for RNA
analysis and DNA analysis and protein
analysis and then obviously use
mathematics to draw conclusions but also
to search for markers that will allow us
to select subpopulations and then
perform functional lunges of these
subpopulations that would actually give
us some information on possible ways to
treat these resistant tumors first thing
that was what that happened was to
actually perform an expression analysis
of the place in denial xenograft cells
so these are the bulk cells and compare
them to the tumor there are two samples
from the two log before and after
treatment and what you can see is that
analysis of this data showed that this
this tumor is part of the basal breast
tumor subtype but it seemed to be a
little bit different than the most of
the other basil other samples that have
been clarified classified as basil
anyway what was reassuring is the fact
that these samples all go together and
they seem to be that therefore
indicating that the pdx reflects as much
as possible the original tumor in terms
of expression profile and that's also
indicated here this was further
strengthened by using a classification
of the tumor based on 150 of 150
signature genes and this so clearly that
the pdx and the primary is part of the
basal
like subtype but basil it's quite an
issue so basal-like is not just for in
order to appreciate the results and
basil like is a heterogeneous group most
of these some tumors are basically
triple negative but it's not identical
triple negative so the vast majority is
had his hormone receptor negative and
her2 negative but they are within this
group are also tumors that can have one
of the hormone receptors or can have
have to present as well similar to the
case that we are investigating now the
capture of these cells require quite a
number of optimizations and I'm showing
you this here to appreciate the issue
that actually like many tumors the cells
are not all of exactly the same shape
and size but there is quite a
distribution of the cells in terms of
sizes as you can see here but that was
the good thing about the the fluid and
system is that we could actually capture
and visualize yourself attacking capture
and measure them in terms of size so
that we can always go back after
expression profiling and see what is the
phenotype of the cells the efficiency
has been optimized to be quite good and
we are able to capture up to 93 cells
from out of 96 position using the system
the next thing is that we check we
perform the cdna synthesis in the chip
and if we run the CD need that has been
generated we can see elected
form electrophoresis we can see that it
actually does contain high molecular
weight cdna then we perform the tag
mentation you can see here the shift
after plaquemine tation and we select
then for our library the size that is
works best with a lumina system now in
order to be sure that actually our
single-cell cdna synthesis is as
efficient as the bulk we also sequence
this reseda nate directly using a PacBio
instrument which is a single molecule
sequencing instrument that actually can
sequence up to 10 and 20 kb of DNA and
here you can see the bulk samples
sequence the average read length of our
bulk samples compared to the single
cells here and what we can see is that
indeed the single cells have a good
distribution of long see DNA fragments
very similar to our bulk samples being
reassured about that we go on to perform
the sequencing and then analyze the data
which required quite a complex approach
that I'm going to go through a little
bit here but one needs to process the
counts as usual remove duplicates and
then use a suite of different softwares
to actually analyze the data and
normalize the data which is quite
challenging in this case how do this the
others the performance of the ridge look
like so here are raw data from single
cell samples from this tumor and what we
can see is that if we sequence the bulk
so this is now something resembling 200
cells from this tumor and we generate
about 17 million reads
for this we can identify close to 20,000
different genes which is close to what
you would expect from the bulk samples
single cells we sequence between five
and seven or ten million reads in this
case and what we see is that we identify
in general something like seven to eight
thousand different genes from the single
cells the mapping rate is quite good and
you can see here that most of the reads
are very useful and it's above zero
point nine percent the SOI 0.9 and I is
the mapping rate which is very good now
how many leads we need depends on it's a
cost issue but in general this graph
shows that with about 10 million reads
one should be able and we worked out
that we can capture most of all the
genes for the single cells it's a matter
of cost and in general one operates in
this area close to probably one or two
million reads depending on you know what
is the aim of the project now how many
reads you get is one thing how well do
they work in covering the different
transcripts is the the important
question anybody I'm showing you here
how we cover transcripts on 500 three
prime end and it is the it's divided
into low medium and high express
transcripts so basically what you can
see is that in the high expect a skit we
get good coverage from five prime to
three prime end
the method has been improved over the
years and we can see here very clear
nice result whereby the profile of the
coverage is resembling what you would
get from the high express transcripts
but you would get in a standard RNA
sequencing using alumina or other
technologies for the medium transcripts
you can see that there was somewhat
biased was the 3 prime end getting rich
that not predominantly to this repayment
compared to the high express transcripts
but now with quite a number of
improvements we can see that in general
we don't get such a predominant bias
anymore for the mid-range transcripts
but apart from a couple of exceptions
shown here for example whereby you will
then take note of the sample and see
whether it should be removed from the
answers or not for the low express
samples the coverage is still very good
so there is some free prime bias but in
general we still cover the five prime
end as you can see here quite well
compared to the three prime end so the
coverage is quite good and this can be
seen also if we project our data on the
UCSC genome browser for example and here
is a housekeeping gene that's not
particularly important but you can see
that independent of how high or how low
it is expressed we cover all the actions
of the gene and here's a more tissue
specific gene it's a keratin gene and we
can see again that we cover all the
reactions of the gene from from the very
five prime to the very three prime end
so the performance of the method is
quite good in covering the entire
transcripts independent of their
expression level
next thing that you do after you analyze
the data is that we take into account
that we put in spikes so we use 92 RNA
spikes from a sec and these have
different sequences and different
content div ratios in terms of
concentrations to each other as well as
different lengths and we use the spikes
as a controls and what we want to see is
that if there is a technical variation
in the experiment from single cell to
single cell and what we project here is
the levels observed for the bulk versus
the single cells and what we can see
here is that the sum of the single cells
reflect nicely correlates nicely with
bulk and that's what you want you want a
correlation of 0.9 or so the other thing
that we do is to see whether there is to
clarify whether it was another level of
technical variation and we look at the
Pearson correlation of each now sample
to each other and they can plot the
candle density and what you want is
basically one peak in general that tells
us that in terms of the ESC see spikes
there is only one population in what we
have captured and the next thing is to
see whether the average or if you add
well one single cell after the other
ending up here like 35 in this case
whether you will capture all the
observations that have been made using
the bulk and in general we want to be at
about one hundred percent in this case
and that's what we see so they this is
the technical part showing that in terms
of cdna synthesis everything went well
in the experiment now the next thing to
do is to look at the MRNA expression and
what we can see here is we compared the
bulk of the
200 fells to again the average of our
single cells and again we achieve a
similar Pearson correlation as before so
it is around point 92.8 now on the other
hand we plot the basin correlation of
each individual cell to each other to
every other and look at the kernel
density and what we can see here is that
in our case there is one main population
but there is a possibility that there is
definitely one more population that is
smaller possibly or two or three
different populations in terms of
behaviors against these behaviors could
be technical or biological but we can
see here where this experiments that
this experiment can lead us into
identifying a number of subpopulations
the other thing that we want to clarify
is whether the if we add one data from
one single cell to the next from 1 to 35
whether whether we will capture all the
information that is in the bulk and in
this case we see that we we capture /
point 8 of what eighty percent or what
we can observe with the bulk this is
quite reassuring so actually it tells
you that if we it points to us being
able to see populations that are about
ten to twenty percent of the out of the
total number of cells then we use in
terms of analyzing the data further we
use the spikes and we look at the fitted
values of the spikes and its most
successful if you take their length into
account and then we use the spikes that
show the best behavior like here to
normalize that
of the samples in the rest of the
transcripts sorry and if we plot here we
plot the variance this is the length and
the spikes I can be seen in blue so we
perform this normalization based on the
spike behavior and we plot then again
the the coefficient of variation is the
square coefficient of variation on the
y-axis and the average normalized read
count here on the x-axis and this allows
us to select basically a group of jeans
that show variation that has a good
chance to reflect the biology and in
this case we took about five to six
hundred genes and what you can see is
that indeed if we use these five nearly
600 genes we can actually separate our
single cells into two possibly three
subpopulations so once we have performed
this analysis and we got this result and
we do the following we look at markers
that are used to classify breast tumors
in two subclasses and in this particular
case we use the Ames method also
developed developed at McGill unlike
hallett group that uses a classifier
based on 150 genes so we take this 150
genes and look at their relationship as
published by the harlot group and see
what subtype it's going to come up with
and what was the result is that our
single cells could be classified into
three groups one was similar sort of
classified to have to us how to like
then basal-like and some were classified
as normal like and this is what we sort
of suspected from the original tomb of
data that it there will be self that
could be classified by that but it has
to be done in order to to be shown the
the same we reproduce using single cells
from the explant culture we take the
single cells from the explained cancer
perform the expression profiling and
apply the aims classifier and again we
see three subpopulations based on like
normal like and here to like so we need
to know that what we have observed
during the quality control that it is
reflected in the behavior of the data
and that we do have at least and maybe
three different subpopulations or even
more but we can be sort of sure that
there are three different subpopulations
in our single cells now in comparison if
we apply the classifier to our single
cells and the bulk that we had a couple
of bulk experiments that we did then
what we see is that the bulk oil is
always classified by applying the same
conditions is always classified as base
alike and this is an important point as
a take-home message we would never have
observed this if we did not analyze the
sample at single-cell level so whatever
subpopulations we take they come up as
basil like once we use bulk cell
analysis even going down to 200 cells
now if we take the classifications that
we have done I showed you that there
were two or three different
subpopulations reflected here what we
have observed is that these sub
populations are enriched for different
subtypes and that can be seen here so a
bit better so what we did was to to
clearly see what genes are correlating
with a particular subtype and there are
two groups of cells that we have here
and what we can see is that the one
group here in red contains the normal
and here to like cells and the other
group contains mostly the basal like
cells and their characteristic is based
on hi Mick expression or hi egfr
expression and we looked at the GFR
because we wanted to have a cell surface
marker that could be used as according
to the scheme I showed you at the
beginning to select the subpopulation in
order to do that we needed a cell
surface marker that will allow us to
actually get the cells and soft and
viewed using facts technologies so you
can see that they'd separate nicely in
these two groups in order to confirm
that and this is in this was done in
collaboration with fluid I'm we used an
assay which is a multiplex protein
extension assay that uses antibodies
against two different antibodies against
the protein target these have two
different illegals and if they are in
proximity you can you get binding of the
other
helping of matching sequence here and
then DNA full DNA is synthesized using
an expansion reaction so once the DNA
fragment is synthesized when we apply
qpcr to analyze the data so we applied
this using a panel develop for breast
cancer and we want to see whether the
protein data will correlate with our
expression data and here you can see
what we get actually if we look at the
mick expression and the egfr expression
by qpcr so we repeat the experiment but
this time we don't perform am RNA
sequencing but we perform
high-throughput qpcr including pcs for
mick and egfr we can see that these two
are and decor negatively correlated and
the same here we perform with the at the
protein level and we get quite similar
data in terms of qpcr so then it was a
matter of confirming though this result
so since we what we have seen from our
expression data was that there were
cells that had hi Mick and cells that
had high GFR so i hope you can see here
i'll show you an example so we look now
at tissue sections and if we stained for
mick and egfr what we see is that they
stained distinct cells and they are
exclusive from each other
and that interestingly we went back and
more acts lab investigated also the
primary tumors and what we can see here
is that a independent of whether you
look at the primary tumor or the patient
arrives in xenograft they are you can
see the populations of hi Mick
containing cells here and here versus
the high EGFR containing cells and they
form distinct groups within the tumor so
we are happy to see that this was
reproduced not only what we see in
single cells was not only reproduced in
the pdx in the hole in tissue sections
from the pdx but also from the tumor
itself and nicely the data you see here
in in this experiment will recapitulate
what we see with a single cell RNA
sequencing in terms of expression of
Mick EGFR and subtype classification now
what was quite interesting is that if we
take if we investigate what happens if
this tumor metastasizes and here is an
example of an early metastasis in the
lung what we see is that this metastasis
is a negative for mick and contains the
EGF ourselves only so it stops the
metastasis at an early stage starts from
the EGFR containing cells this doesn't
mean that the metastasis is driven by
GFR but it's just Adam it is a marker
for this subpopulation of cells from
this tumor
now what happens next is that above the
beginning we have only egfr cells once
the tumor growth then it starts to be
containing subpopulation that is now
expressing high levels of mick which
continues to be so exclusive exclusive
of the subpopulation that contains a
high egfr and what is interesting is
that basically the metastasis here it
has a now recapitulate is tostada to
recapitulate the subpopulations that
make the original tumor the same is
observed when you grow the cells in
spheres so they contain cells that are
either high in egfr or I've high in Mick
then the idea was ok we can see this but
is it actually something that can be
observed in other tumors and indeed here
is an example out of 11 different tumors
that have been analyzed at this level of
detail and you can see here an example
of three tumors shown here whereby we do
have the same profile it's it contains
high GFR or hi Mick cells that are in
distinct areas of the tumor and so a
very similar distribution as our
original index case this is not always
the case so in the next slides also the
other tumors that have been investigated
but what is interesting is that indeed
the tumors can be split into ones that
have make somehow egfr and low make and
obviously tumors that have both but my
point here is that if if you look at
these tumors
performing expression profiling of the
tumor will not allow you to distinguish
between these two subpopulations now
since what we wanted to achieve was to
have a cell surface marker to fish out
the one subpopulation from the other
this is what was done and the next step
in experiments performed by Paul savage
in more acts lab was to actually use
facts to sort the egfr positive
subpopulation and to our surprise this
this is the population that can grow
into most fears while the negative
population which is the biggest
population does not grow in TMR spheres
and this experiment has been repeated
several times giving consistent result
and again if we look at now in the
animal again it is the high egfr
population that generates tumors that
are quite big while the the negative
population is quite inefficient me
containing is inefficient in actually
generating tumors and that can been seen
in this type of analysis here and here
so after this we can say that indeed the
method has allowed us to identify
subpopulations that would not have been
identified using bulk analysis and that
actually these sub populations are
functionally distinct and have different
growth and metastasis properties from
each other and are now available for
further functional characterization in
order to see which compounds would be
effective against which subpopulation
now in parallel in the last minutes I
will cover
the fact that you can use the same
system to actually look at the genome of
these samples and this is being done
through whole genome amplification and
after whole genome replication in the
chip we perform an xterra capture which
is a game tag mentation based and
followed by exome sequencing does so
quickly the data so if the method works
quite well here are the control samples
the tumor and xenograft which we
sequence at a very high depth of at
minimum 500 fault coverage and the
single cells shown here which have been
a sequence of the coverage of 39 fold
but if you put all these two lists
together you end up with a 1380 fault
coverage of the tumor the mapping rate
as you can see here from the single
cells that the performance of the the
whole experiment was indistinguishable
between single cells on here or most of
them compared to a standard exome
capture shown here and if we wanted to
look at our just go to the next slide
quickly so we analyze the data and what
we see is that we could identify a quite
a good number of possible damaging snips
in the tumors and 27 thousand of those
have been identified of which most were
not in DB snip and I'm showing this here
another demonstrate that because we
sequenced also the germline all these
were not aware homozygous homozygous
reference the germline and shown in the
tumor obviously we compare the different
tumor samples before and after treatment
with the pdx and then the single-cell
experiments and we see nicely that these
are overlapping
entirely and the pdx can capture the
information will be captured from the
pdx and the single cells reflects the
information present in the tumor and
what is interesting is if you take the
snips and you look at whether the single
cell the information that is found from
you know the calls from the single cells
capture the calls from the bulk and you
can see that this actually is quite
effective and we capture a hundred
percent of about whether this is 200
cells or unamplified genomic DNA from
the tumor shown here again with a single
cells by sequencing about 80 81 single
cells we capture the information that is
contained within the tumor sample and we
use this in order to conclude we use
this this information to cluster the
single self and that's shown here and
indeed we can see that we can identify
two or three subpopulations so the
pattern we get is very similar to the
pattern we get if we use about 600 genes
according to their expression behavior
then we take this data and project them
to the RNA sequencing data so we use our
net sequencing data to discover
expressed now mutations and I'm showing
you this to show to actually simply say
the following that these indeed may be
split into different categories in two
different subpopulations in terms of
behavior but this does not explain the
clustering we have seen according to
subtype based on the expression level so
therefore so far we don't have an
indication that it was the actual
mutations that drove the behavior of
these subpopulations it can explain why
in the metastasis we have EGFR let's say
contain the GFR containing subpopulation
and then from that you can derive the
meat containing subpopulation so I know
to conclude we have performed the
expression analysis that allowed us to
successfully identify at least two
distinct subpopulations with distinct
functional properties in terms of
metastasis and proliferation we also
found a lot of genes but this is less
interesting so I'm not covering that I'm
finishing by saying that the we had no
evidence so far that the mutations were
driving the the clustering we have seen
with expression profiling and this can
be used now to develop treatments for
these subpopulations and I finish here
by thanking all the funders thank you
thank you dr. a Goose's for taking time
to be with us today and bring us this
important information before we get
started on our questions which we
already do have a few I want to remind
our audience how to submit questions
questions can be sent via the green Q&A
button at the lower left of the
presentation window and we will get to
as many of them as we can our first
question for the pdx model does the
number of initial tumor cells
transferred to influence the expression
profiles for instance if 10 to the third
10 to the 4 through 10 to the 5th during
the propagation of the tumor does that
change the expression profile the this
can change I mean not all and there have
been extensive publications in nature
and sell about this issue the P it's not
a general phenomenon that they if you do
the pdx out of ten or hundred thousand
cells that it will reflect the
expression profile of the original tumor
so one issue is that
it is a bit unpredictable up to what
extent the the expression profile of the
of the pdx will reflect the tumor in our
case what we can say is that there is a
very good overlap between the the pdx
and the tumor but it's not clear how
many how many cells would be required in
each particular case to achieve that but
it has been where you do a number of
experiments until the pdx does actually
reflect it the gym oh I see thank you we
have another question can you describe
the challenges of using single-cell RNA
seek from X plant culture the biggest
one of the biggest challenges in from
the culture is that the self have to be
dissociated from the culture surface and
that brings with it quite enough a lot
of debris and one has to optimize it
using different methods in order to
dissociate the cells from the culture
surface without actually carrying
different bits and pieces from from the
surface itself so i found this the
biggest challenge in our case the debris
that comes with it there the other
challenge is to get the excellent
culture right because what we have
observed is that the expression pattern
of the cells in culture can sift from
the original patterns observed in the
xenograft itself so one creates a
kriffing to twice or three times it
sounds quite complex we have another
question will single cell sequencing
apply to epigenetic study yes it is
possible so there is intensive work
going on to develop
methylation analysis at single-cell
level and it is possible and but there
is a lot of development going on and ish
it would be there will be standardized
methods to perform extensive methylation
status from single cells great we have
time for one more question an attendee
says thank you for a great presentation
and asks can we use single-cell RNA seek
analysis for other not mammalian animals
such as chicken we have used yeah there
is no reason why not I think one has to
use a cell capture system that is
suitable for the particular cells but I
think for example the one we use has a
very wide applications I think it gets
tricky it's not you know if you go
towards very small cells like in yeast
it's going it's going to be difficult
and you use special microfluidic devices
but in general the analysis described
and the other methods like drop sick etc
are very well suitable for analyzing any
cell type thank you doctor a Goose's
that is all the time we have I would
like to thank lab roots for making this
webcast possible today's webcast is
going to be available for on-demand
viewing through November of 2016 and
attendees today will receive an email
alerting them as to when that webcast is
available for replay we would invite you
to form forward that email to any of
your colleagues who could not log on
directly today thank you again to dr.
yiannis magusis for bringing us this
information and making this webcast
possible we hope we see you again thank
you very much it was a pleasure thank
you bye-bye